[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las
principales noticias las más destacadas
relacionadas con la pandemia de kobe 19
en nuestro continente a continuación les
presento los principales temas que vamos
a desarrollar en este programa vamos a
ver en detenimiento cómo está la
situación en argentina son críticos los
números allí en cuanto al número de
contagios fallecidos y también algunos
expertos ya han indicado que este país
comienza a convertirse en un foco de
contagio en américa del sur muchos
ciudadanos también salieron a lo largo
de esta semana las calles de diferentes
ciudades para rechazar la lenta
vacunación del plan nacional allí en
argentina y también para rechazar las
restricciones impuestas por el gobierno
pero también está en veremos y en total
incertidumbre la realización de la copa
américa hay en argentina vamos a ver
cómo está la situación hablaremos de ese
anuncio inesperado del presidente de
eeuu joe biden quien solicitó al
servicio de inteligencia de su país
investigar en sólo 90 días el origen del
hobby 19 como era de esperarse este
pedido no fue muy bien recibido por
de china que se sintió un poco
confrontada con eeuu este pedido tiene
lugar cuando la o ms tras una
investigación en china en wuhan confirmó
que era muy remota la posibilidad de que
el coronavirus stars co2 se hubiera
fugado de un laboratorio tal parece que
a washington no confía mucho en este
reporte no lo convenció y por eso está
solicitando esta nueva investigación y
vamos a dar también un vistazo a la
situación en colombia países que al
igual que argentina hace frente a un
largo pico de contagio que comenzó en
semana santa pero colombia lleva también
un mes de estallido social y eso
complica mucho la situación y lo vemos
reflejado en las cifras más de 20.000
nuevos casos en algunos de los días de
esta semana más de 500 fallecidos y una
ocupación de uso superior al 90 por
ciento aún con este panorama las
autoridades de bogotá la capital
decidieron abrir por completo la ciudad
a la vida comercial social y nocturna a
partir del 8 de julio
pues vamos a comenzar primero entonces
con cifras con cifras de los casos al
cierre de estas semanas cifras con
respecto al acumulado en los casos
confirmados de kobe 19 por millón de
habitantes de cada uno de los países que
les vamos a presentar vamos a hacer este
recorrido por los países de la zona
andina comenzamos con chile que tiene 70
763 casos por cada millón de habitantes
pero tiene 58,900 le sigue bolivia con
30,900 75 casos por cada millón de
habitantes en este país mientras que
ecuador llega ya a los 23 mil 937 casos
por cada millón de habitantes
y vamos a hacer un balance de cómo está
la situación cómo termina esta semana
algunos de los puntos de nuestro
continente vamos a comenzar en argentina
allí se mantienen las restricciones y
también repunte de casos llegaron
también más vacunas a lo largo de esta
semana vamos a conversar entonces con
natalio con soy nuestro corresponsal en
la ciudad de buenos aires para conocer
cómo está la situación
hola a natalio y bueno pues comencemos
entonces por la situación cómo fue esta
semana en cuanto a cifras críticas
muchos picos que superaron los 20 mil
casos de contagio y sobre todo hay un
aumento en las provincias cuando la
parte crítica de este contagio estaba en
la ciudad de buenos aires- la capital
argentina vive un momento muy difícil de
la pandemia de koi 19 el jueves se
superaron por primera vez los 40 mil
casos reportados en 24 horas van varios
días con alrededor de 500 muertes
diarias
las terapias intensivas están
atravesando un momento de mucha presión
además con pacientes en terapia más
jóvenes que en la primera ola es una
situación difícil y grave desde el 22 de
mayo hasta este domingo 30 por este
contexto el gobierno bien puesto unas
medidas más restrictivas sobre todo para
contener la circulación con la
posibilidad de circular solo para
sectores esenciales y muy pocas
posibilidades de circulación para el
resto de los ciudadanos en prácticamente
todo el país hasta ahora lo que está
menos que no se van a extender esas
restricciones si se van a repetir y así
estaba previsto el primer fin de semana
de junio y tal vez existe la posibilidad
de que restricciones intermitentes como
estos nueve días que se cumplen el
domingo vuelvan a aparecer en los
dos meses si no logran contenerse el
aumento de casos aquí en argentina
natalio hay un tema importante sobre la
mesa y es la copa américa colombia de
argentina eran las sedes elegidas para
este torneo profesional de fútbol
colombia ya por el estallido social y
también por el aumento de los casos no
va a albergar ninguno de estos partidos
pero argentina también está haciendo
frente a una problemática con este
aumento de casos que dicen allí las
autoridades
hasta el momento de la emisión de este
programa no había una respuesta
definitiva a las opciones son vuelos que
se organice íntegramente en argentina
después de la salida de colombia como
sede compartida la otra opción es que se
sume chile y comparta con argentina al
ser sede de la copa américa y también
está la posibilidad tal vez un poco más
remota en este momento de que argentina
no sea sede en ese caso habría que ver
cómo lo resuelve la conmebol hay
argumentos a favor y en contra de que
argentina sea sede de la copa américa en
este contexto quienes están a favor
dicen que el riesgo relativo y riesgo
sanitario de organizar el evento es muy
bajo y quienes están en contra
argumentan que en un contexto tan duro
de la pandemia y con tantas
restricciones para el público general
para los habitantes del país no es
conveniente organizar un evento de estas
características de hecho un reciente
informe de la consultora poliarquía aquí
en argentina da cuenta que el 70% de las
personas que encuestaron dijeron que no
era conveniente que no estaban de
acuerdo con que se realice la copa
américa en argentina este año en el
mundo del deporte atentos allí a lo que
sucede en argentina
en torno al número de contagios para
saber si vamos a tener copa américa y en
este país suramericano también es
importante hay en argentina dar un
vistazo a los índices de vacunación la
llegada de más lotes de vacunas y
también a esas marchas que tuvieron
lugar a lo largo de esta semana
rechazando las restricciones este
confinamiento de 9 días y también la
lentitud con la que avanza el proceso de
vacunación en las provincias sobre todo
hasta este viernes más o menos nueve
millones cien mil personas que es algo
así como el 20 por ciento de la
población argentina había recibido al
menos una dosis de alguna de las vacunas
que se están dando en el país que son la
de astrazéneca las burning b y las
scinopharm y el gobierno anunció que
este lunes se espera la llegada de
2.150.000 dosis aproximadamente de
vacunas de astrazéneca y eso va a llevar
el total de vacunas que ha recibido
argentina a algo más de 17 millones y
medio algunas todavía están en proceso
de distribución y aplicación por
supuesto mientras tanto además en
argentina sigue el debate para entender
por qué el país no firmó un acuerdo con
facer para recibir dosis de su vacuna
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta que en
argentina se realizó una parte
importante del estudio de fase 3 de esta
vacuna bueno por ahora el gobierno dice
que las conversaciones siguen adelante y
está la expectativa de que en algún
momento tal vez se logre un acuerdo con
esa farmacéutica bueno natalio pues más
que claro el panorama en argentina y
seguimos atentos a lo que pueda pasar
con la copa américa que tiene que
definir pronto gracias por este reporte
desde buenos aires nos vamos al país
vecino allí en chile el gobierno de ese
país liderado por el presidente
sebastián piñera indicó que chile pasará
a una nueva fase de movilidad en su
camino hacia la apertura total las
autoridades señalaron que las personas
que ya tienen las dos dosis de
vacunación y después de 14 días de haber
recibido la última inoculación podrán
tener mayores libertades en cuanto a la
movilidad tanto al interior de las
ciudades como desplazarse también a las
diferentes regiones que conforman ese
país veamos
buenas noticias para los chilenos
vacunados contra el hobbit 19 las
personas que hayan sido inmunizadas por
completo podrán gozar de un pase de
movilidad base que les dará la libertad
para desplazarse sin problemas tal y
como lo hacían antes de la pandemia así
lo dio a conocer el presidente sebastián
piñera esta semana implementaremos un
pase de movilidad que dará mayor el
grado de libertad y de movilidad a las
personas que hayan completado
íntegramente su proceso de vacunación
con las dosis y los tiempos requeridos
el documento que entra en vigor este 26
de mayo consiste en un código qr que
podrá obtenerse de manera digital o
física y sólo se entregará 14 días
después de haber sido inmunizados por
completo sin embargo la medida ha
generado algunas críticas pues hay
quienes no la consideran oportunas la
implementación de un pase de movilidad
no es apropiada en este momento
epidemiológico en primer lugar porque
este va a aumentar la movilidad y con
esto el riesgo de que tengamos mayores
contagios en segundo lugar porque esto
puede generar una falsa sensación de
seguridad a las personas vacunadas que
tienen que mantener sus medidas
autocuidado de los casi 19 millones de
habitantes que tienen chile más de 17
millones han recibido al menos una dosis
de la vacuna mientras que más de 7
millones ya están vacunados por completo
esto representa poco más del 40 por
ciento de su población total y vamos a
orar la bienvenida al doctor carlos
eduardo pérez él es infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia él está
con nosotros para conversar y también
para analizar algunos temas destacados
de esta semana doctor pérez como siempre
un gusto tenerlo aquí en el programa y
comienzo esta consulta preguntándole por
ese anuncio que dieron a conocer algunos
científicos sobre el hallazgo de una
nueva variante en el estado de sao paulo
en brasil y también una nueva variante
en perú llamada la variante andina qué
información hay sobre estos dos casos
la aparición de las nuevas variantes es
algo que se espera en la medida que se
haya incrementado los contagios a través
de la dirigencia genómica es decir
secuenciando los virus mirando cómo es
las características se han encontrado
hasta todas nuevas variantes en esta
semana se han descrito y qué significa
eso muchas de estas variantes no tienen
importancia pero algunas muestran
particular importancia por dos razones o
aumentan su contagiosidad o pueden ser
mucho más
aumenta la virulencia es decir que
enferman más a las personas lo que
sabemos actualmente es que es muy
probable que éstas hayan incrementado la
capacidad de contagio y expliquen los
picos que han tenido en brásil sostenido
y lo que pasó en chile y perú estas
estas variantes simplemente significan
que debemos mantener el distanciamiento
y los procesos de vacunación pero entre
más incremento de contagios más
probabilidades que en un futuro parezcan
no ordinarios
la vacunación como el arma para poder
combatir esta pandemia doctor india es
un país que lleva varias semanas en un
pico constante y aumenta casos y sigue
aumentando y rompe sus propios récords
pero ahora este país ha decretado una
epidemia de una enfermedad llamada el
hongo negro de qué se trata
debemos tener atención en américa latina
por la posible llegada de este hongo qué
información hay
es muy bueno santiago que aclaremos este
punto lo que pasa es que el kobe produce
una lesión pulmonar y este hongo es un
germen oportunista no es un virus es
como es un hongo que infecta los
pulmones después de las personas durante
el proceso de kobe este hongo negro se
llama músculo de hace parte de la
familia de las mocos micosis son hongos
que son resistentes a los tratamientos
convencionales pero este es un germen
que aparece básicamente por el daño
pulmonar y porque requerimos dar
tratamientos con esteroides que
facilitan el ingreso este hongo entonces
no quiere decir que vaya a américa
latina o que se expanda como si fuera
una bacteria o como si fuera un virus es
un germen oportunista que aparece en
cada uno de los individuos que ha tenido
un daño pulmonar extenso y que se ha
acompañado de una inmunosupresión
profunda es una situación que hemos
visto en algunos pacientes sakana en la
región pero
en india es inusitado el número de casos
y por eso le ha llamado la atención a la
comunidad médica claro además que ya hay
un primer caso reportado en uruguay dr
por las redes sociales varias personas
preguntaron por ese anuncio que hizo la
farmacéutica pfiezer bayón tec de
espaciar un poco más el tiempo entre la
primera dosis y la inoculación de la
segunda dosis dijeron que podrían
ampliarse unos cuantos días más porque
lo proponen qué beneficios tiene y
también importante decir ese anuncio de
la autoridad sanitaria de la unión
europea que indicó que va a inocular la
vacuna de facer by ontex en adolescentes
de entre 12 y 15 años también qué
beneficios hay para los planes de
vacunación y para la inmunización en
general
definitivamente en los intervalos de
administración es algo que se va
construyendo el conocimiento en la
medida de que va a cursando la pandemia
inicialmente el curso de tres semanas
con la vacuna de parcero de cuatro
semanas color una de moderna fue en todo
caso para acelerar los estudios clínicos
y para mirar su eficacia hoy se sabe que
cuando se espacio a 12 semanas es se
incrementa el poder de generar
anticuerpos eso que involucra que desde
la primera vacuna se protege un gran
porcentaje y que darlo a las 12 semanas
probablemente incremente la efectividad
distinto de lo que se hace a 21 días eso
quiere decir no necesariamente que las
personas que se vacunaron a con el
intervalo de tres semanas se tengan que
revacunar eso todavía no está claro sino
que las personas que se van a vacunar en
un futuro lo haga en un espacio
probablemente de 12 semanas como lo más
razonable
de otro lado es buena noticia que
recientemente en eeuu con la casa
farmacéutica moderna y hoy con la con la
emea es la agencia europea se
estandarizó y se demostró la seguridad
de la vacunación entre los 12 y 15 años
eso permite que estas personas que estos
adolescentes reciban la vacuna y hagan
parte de esta inmunidad de rebaño que
necesitamos en este momento
doctor pere después muchas gracias por
despejar todas nuestras dudas les
recuerdo que ustedes puede dejar sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
del canal y al mi cuenta personal en
twitter vamos a cambiar de tema vamos a
ver más cifras de cómo cierra esta
semana la vacunación en algunos de los
países de américa latina veamos los
números del consolidado de américa del
sur nos dice que ya en esta región han
sido inoculadas 114 puntos 33 millones
de dosis para combatir el cob y 19 en
los 19 territorios que comprenden estas
regiones decir 13 países un territorio
francés que el guayana francesa y 5
dependencias en la costa norte de
suramérica chile avanza rápidamente con
18.0 dos millones de dosis le sigue
argentina con 11,50 millones de dosis
suministradas ya colombia con 8 millones
84 millones de dosis ya lo decíamos 8
millones mientras que en centroamérica
veamos cómo está el salvador allí han
inoculado 1.83 millones de dosis costa
rica- muy de cerca al salvador con 146
millones de dosis
y ya lo hablamos con el doctor pérez en
el estado de sao paulo que es el más
poblado de brasil y también el más
afectado por la pandemia del cob y 19
los científicos se anunciaron la
aparición de una nueva variante de kobe
19 esta serie sería la segunda variante
encontrada en brásil la primera fue en
la ciudad de manaos en el norte del país
algo similar está ocurriendo en perú
también lo mencionábamos donde
encontraron una variante denominada
variante andina que ya supone el 80% de
los casos que se están presentando en
ese país
hace cuatro días ya ir bolsonaro se daba
este baño de multitudes
bolsonaro para mí es el retorno de la
libertad del retorno de mi país soy una
patriota estoy con él en medio de un
repunte de casos en brásil científicos
anunciaron la aparición de una nueva
variante de kobe 19 en la región de sao
paulo un nuevo sobresalto para un país
que cuenta ya más de 450 mil muertes por
este virus la sociedad brasileña de
virología afirmó que esta nueva variante
contiene una mutación presente también
en las variantes india y californiana y
sospechan asimismo que deriva del mismo
linaje que la variante de manaos que
provocó el colapso del sistema sanitario
entre marzo y abril por el momento se
desconoce si esta nueva variante es más
contagiosa o letal que las originales en
perú el ministerio de salud confirmó la
presencia de la denominada como variante
andina ya detectada en numerosos países
de la región el titular de salud óscar
ugarte afirmó que el 80 por ciento de
los casos actuales de coronavirus en el
país derivan de esta variante lo que aún
no se ha podido confirmar es si la
variante es más letal que la brasileña y
británica también presentes en el país
lado ms tampoco la clasifica por el
momento
su preocupación sus dos categorías para
las nuevas variantes confío mucho en el
procedimiento que están haciendo de
vacunación si no confiamos estamos
perdidos tenemos que confiar el
presidente francisco sagasti confirmó el
pasado viernes que el país cuenta ya con
60 millones de dosis suficientes para
inmunizar a la población al final del
año afirmó este proceso ya ha ayudado a
bajar las cifras de contagios durante el
mes de mayo en un país que suma ya 68
mil 470 muertes desde el inicio de la
pandemia bueno y ahora demos un vistazo
como avanzó la vacunación en américa del
norte vamos a hablar del número de dosis
suministradas en cada uno de los
territorios que les vamos a mencionar
comenzamos en eeuu que es el líder
indiscutible de la vacunación a nivel
mundial con 290 millones de dosis
suministradas hasta ahora le siguen
méxico con 27 millones de dosis ya
inoculadas en tercer lugar está canadá
muy cerca de méxico con 22.35 millones
de dosis pasamos a bermuda allí han sido
suministradas 68 mil 822 dosis y
cerramos con groenlandia
de parte del continente americano han
inoculado allí 20 mil 910 dosis hasta el
momento
bueno vamos a profundizar en este tema
para eso conectamos con cristóbal
vázquez nuestro corresponsal en la
ciudad de washington quien desde la sede
de la organización panamericana de la
salud nos va a dar más detalles hola
cristóbal como siempre un gusto
saludarlos gracias por acompañarnos en
el programa y fue destacado a lo largo
de esta semana se anunció del presidente
yo vaivén que pidió una investigación
sobre el origen de el coronavirus en
china que detalles hubo del desarrollo
de esta noticia y sobre todo la reacción
de china
el presidente baile le dio la cia y a
otros agencias de inteligencia
estadounidense a 90 días para que
entreguen un reporte sobre el origen del
cob y 19 es que la inteligencia
estadounidense no tiene un consenso
sobre su origen y no descarta que el
virus se haya filtrado accidentalmente
del instituto de virología de buján
radio de bailén viene después de que
organismos de inteligencia encontrarán
nueva evidencia que no permitió a eeuu
descartar esta opción a pesar de que la
organización mundial de la salud haya
publicado un estudio hace unos meses
apenas diciendo que el virus surgió del
contacto entre animales y humanos y que
la acusación que inicialmente hizo
donald trump era extremadamente
improbable
al respecto china reaccionó diciendo que
al contrario que el origen del virus se
dio en un laboratorio en maryland en
estados unidos y de bailén está
manipulando la verdad y los hechos
cristóbal es impresionante la cantidad
de latinoamericanos y personas del
caribe que están viajando hacia los eeuu
para recibir allí vacunas del cob y 19
esto por supuesto en eeuu lo están
recibiendo muy bien porque se están
moviendo la economía y también están
haciendo uso de una cantidad de vacunas
que no están siendo inoculadas en los
ciudadanos estadounidenses que dicen
allí
los aeropuertos en eeuu vuelven cada vez
más a recuperar su tráfico con muchos
turistas de américa latina del mundo
que vienen por sus vacunas y es que la
difícil accesibilidad en países
latinoamericanos a la vacuna y la alta
oferta además de vacunas en eeuu ha
hecho que muchos estados y principales
ciudades del país como nueva york' como
washington y miami que están que fueron
afectadas económicamente en la pandemia
pues inviten al turismo de vacunas como
una opción para recuperarse
económicamente de hecho el alcalde de
nueva york envió de blasio dijo
abiertamente que su ciudad es una gran
opción para ir a vacunarse y que fuera
de ir a visitar pues además podrían
acogerse y poder ponerse la vacuna
abiertamente actualmente en 24 estados
en este país no se requiere residencia
para acceder a la vacuna y en otros 25
estados no se requiere tener permiso de
trabajo alguna prueba de que se viva ya
para acceder a la vacuna
cristóbal y este país sigue
indestronable en el número de personas
vacunadas en los números también de
dosis inoculadas sigue siendo el líder
mundial en este aspecto incluso en
muchas personas que también han optado
por no vacunarse allí cómo está
avanzando el plan de vacunación nacional
en los 50 estados
hay que decir que yo vaya ence atrás o
la meta de que para el 4 de julio día de
la independencia de eeuu al menos el 70%
de los adultos en este país tengan al
menos una dosis ya al menos 50 por
ciento de los adultos estadounidenses
tiene una dosis contra el kobe y el 40
por ciento de los adultos está
completamente vacunado esto quiere decir
que al menos 165 millones de personas
han sido vacunados en eeuu los
proveedores están administrando cerca de
1.6 millones de vacunas al día y la
vacuna que más se está ofreciendo es
para ser seguida de moderna y después
johnson y johnson recordemos que para
lograr la inmunidad de rebaño se
necesita que al menos entre el 70 y el
90 por ciento de niños y adultos en este
país estén vacunados en cuanto a los
casos el promedio esta semana es de
23.000 casos y las muertes son de 496 el
estado más afectado es la florida
cristóbal y para avanzar en este plan de
vacunación nacional los gobiernos tanto
locales como el gobierno federal han
hecho uso de todo tipo de estrategias
para convencer a los ciudadanos sobre
todo convencer a aquellos que tienen
dudas o que definitivamente no quieren
vacunarse hemos visto imágenes muy
graciosas gobiernos que ofrecen tiquetes
de teatro para para ir a diferentes
espectáculos sorteos incluso hasta
hamburguesas que han hecho
los líderes han promovido muchos
incentivos para aumentar la vacunación
uno de los ejemplos a seguir en eeuu ha
sido el del estado de ohio que tiene una
lotería de un millón de dólares a cinco
personas que muestran en prueba de
vacunación esto ha hecho que este estado
tenga uno de los índices de vacunación
más altos en eeuu y que las loterías a
los vacunados ya hayan empezado a
implementarse en estados también como
nueva york maryland y oregón entre otros
se están ofreciendo también becas
completas para universidades y el
gobernador de west virginia incluso
anunció bonos de 100 dólares para los
jóvenes que se vacunen además de esto
empresas están ofreciendo vacaciones y
bonos para incentivar a que la gente se
vacune y pues entre incentivos también
curiosos está el de regalar cervezas
helado hamburguesas y pases semanales en
transporte público a las personas
vacunadas tal parece que todo es válido
para alcanzar esa inmunidad del rebaño
muchas gracias cristóbal por este
reporte pues ya lo estamos mencionando
precisamente la gran llegada
y ciudadanos suramericanos
centroamericanos y del caribe al sur de
los eeuu y también a la ciudad de nueva
york y washington para vacunarse
precisamente allí en la ciudad de miami
en el sur de la florida ante nivel sin
nuestro corresponsal nos da más detalles
de cómo está manejando esta situación
allí
estamos en uno de los centros de
vacunación más grandes del sur de la
florida
aquí se distribuyen más de 700 dosis de
la vacuna cada día desde hace unas
semanas estos centros también están
abiertos a personas no residentes del
estado y también a turistas por eso
muchos de ellos se aprovechan para
viajar expresamente hasta eeuu
especialmente desde américa latina donde
no hay restricciones de viaje para
aprovechar y ponerse la vacuna aquí
muchos de ellos se sienten satisfechos
por cómo está siendo este sistema de
vacunación ya que sus respectivos países
de américa latina esa distribución está
siendo mucho más lenta si yo vengo desde
méxico para recibir la dosis porque
todavía no han concluido con la
las personas de la tercera edad en asia
es que allí es más rápido y tras
vacunarse muchos de estos turistas
empiezan a quitarse la mascarilla y
viven una vida normal y eso tiene un
impacto directo en el sector turístico
restaurantes completamente llenos y
hoteles rozando la plena ocupación aquí
nadie se acuerda de la pandemia
me siento esté más relajado ya una vida
normal ya puedo andar sin mataría ando
un poco más protegido lógicamente
también no no se sabía hasta cuándo las
vacunas serán gratuitas para los de
fuera pero se ha visto que esta
inversión está siendo muy buena para
reactivar una parte de la economía
pues si en el estado de la florida y en
eeuu en general están recuperando ya la
normalidad un caso completamente
contrario está ocurriendo en colombia un
país que está viviendo un pico muy largo
de contagios y está produciendo
muchísimas personas fallecidas una alta
ocupación de asís y también un alto
número de contagios diarios y esto en
medio del contexto del gran estallido
social que lleva ya cuatro semanas vamos
a profundizar en estos temas con andrés
meza desde la redacción de france 24 en
bogotá la capital colombiana andrés
gracias por acompañarnos hoy por primera
vez aquí en el programa en kobe 19 la
semana en américa y comienzo por
preguntarle colombia al igual que brasil
y que argentina está superando sus
propias cifras de récords de contagiados
fallecidos e incluso de personas
vacunadas cómo está el panorama allí
para el cierre de la semana
santiago colombia hace frente a una
doble crisis la primera la pandemia del
cobi 19 que sigue rompiendo semana a
semana las cifras y un estallido social
que ha entorpecido la efectividad de las
medidas adoptadas para hacer frente a la
crisis sanitaria esta semana por ejemplo
colombia registró un récord de contagios
diarios al alcanzar los 25 mil 92 casos
esto eleva el total de casos a 3
millones 319 mil desde que comenzó la
emergencia la cifra de fallecidos de
esta semana ha alcanzado un nuevo pico
de 513 muertos el total ya alcanza los
86 mil 693 personas fallecidas pero la
otra cara de la moneda también nos deja
cifras récord y estamos hablando de la
vacunación precisamente el miércoles fue
el día en que más personas fueron
inoculadas desde que comenzó la campaña
de inmunización con 229 mil 124 dosis
suministradas de las cuales unas 22 mil
242 eran segundas dosis de esta manera
colombia estaba por alcanzar los 9
millones de vacunados al haber recibido
en los últimos días lotes de vacunas de
las farmacéuticas pfizer
si novak bueno dos caras completamente
diferentes dos caras de la moneda andrés
es muy fácil concluir que si están
aumentando los casos están aumentando
los fallecidos también está aumentando
la ocupación de las ucis de las salas de
cuidado intensivo para tratar a personas
con kobe 19 que dicen allí las
autoridades sanitarias que cifras están
reportando a nivel nacional y a nivel de
bogotá a la ciudad capital
el tercer pico de contagios en colombia
un ciclo de la pandemia que comenzó tras
la semana santa ha generado una mayor
carga hospitalaria y mayor letalidad así
lo indicó el ministerio de salud de
colombia o el ministro de salud de
colombia fernando ruiz que también
especificó que esta alta
transmisibilidad se debe a nuevas
variantes introducidas por casos
importados y también debido a que el
país cumplió un mes de manifestaciones
protestas y concentraciones ciudadanas
en las que muchas veces no se cumplen
los protocolos de bioseguridad a nivel
nacional la ocupación de las salas de
cuidados intensivos llegar al 85 7 por
ciento teniendo en cuenta de las 13.000
unidades disponibles unas seis mil están
siendo usadas con pacientes que tienen
con 19 el departamento de antioquia y la
ciudad de bogotá son las más críticas la
capital se encuentra con un 95 6 por
ciento de ocupación situación que tiene
en alerta a la ciudadanía y por supuesto
a las autoridades antes también fue una
total sorpresa esta semana que la
alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez
anunciara que a partir del 8 de junio en
la ciudad abre completamente en materia
comercial en materia social y también se
va a reactivar la vida nocturna
pero vemos que las cifras no están
acompañando una recuperación en el tema
sanitario porque lo hace
pues pese a este panorama de alto número
de contagios y alta ocupación la
alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez
presentó a los comerciantes y
empresarios una propuesta para reabrir
por completo la capital el 8 de junio
para esa fecha se espera que sea
retirado el toque de queda nocturno y
también la ley seca la decisión la tomó
según lópez teniendo en cuenta el punto
de vista del contexto social económico y
político en el marco del estallido
social que representa un profundo
descontento de los ciudadanos y una
profunda desconfianza en la
institucionalidad que se vio agudizado
en los últimos meses por el aumento de
la pobreza el desempleo y también el
difícil acceso a la educación la
alcaldesa de los más de 8 millones de
capitalinos dijo que toma la decisión
porque las prioridades de la ciudadanía
cambiar antes muchas gracias por este
completo reporte desde la redacción de
france 24 en bogotá en colombia y un
gusto haberlo tenido por primera vez
aquí en el programa seguimos atentos a
lo que sucede en brasil también este
país sigue con un largo pico de contagio
que amenaza con conectarse con otro pico
de una tercera ola que está por comenzar
en ese país brasil registra más de 16
millones 300 mil casos allí
unos cuatrocientos cincuenta y seis mil
674 personas ya han fallecido a lo largo
de esta emergencia sanitaria y esta
semana brasil también contabilizó en
solamente un día dos mil 398 nuevos
casos por como bill 19 también
contabilizaron allí más de 80 mil 486
casos o personas que han reportado tener
síntomas de kobe 19 asimismo fue
detectado ya lo decíamos un primer caso
de la variante de india en el estado de
san pablo allí se suman a seis casos que
fueron reportados en el estado de
maranháo en el noreste de ese país todos
estos siete casos son casos importados
y en nuestra sección en redes veamos
otras noticias destacadas de la semana
aquí en kobe 19 en esta oportunidad
estaremos enfocados en canadá por
ejemplo queremos invitarlos para que
vean este reportaje del programa en foco
de france 24 en el que hacemos un
panorama de la primera ola de contagio
de kobe 19 en ese país que en su momento
dejó 70 por ciento de las muertes que
ocurrieron allí fueron en centros para
personas de la tercera edad una
investigación exclusiva de france 24 que
pueden ver en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom y también en nuestro
canal de youtube
en esta siguiente publicación también de
france 24 punto con más de 50 países
piden explicaciones a la o ms por
acusaciones de abusos sexuales en medio
de esta crisis sanitaria por la pandemia
del hobby 19 decenas de países
manifestaron su preocupación por las
alegaciones de que varios directivos de
la oms se emitieron señalar casos de
abusos sexuales cometidos por personal
de este organismo y expresaron su
frustración por la lentitud de la
investigación que está en curso y
terminamos con esta publicación del
diario el país de uruguay que titula
coronavirus en uruguay récord de casos
activos y se superaron ya las 4.000
muertes desde el inicio de la pandemia
esta publicación indica que son 36 mil
121 de las personas que se encuentran
atravesando esta enfermedad de ellas 507
están internadas en salas de cuidados
intensivos en diferentes hospitales
uruguayos
es todo por el momento aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa nos vemos la
próxima semana
[Música]